so it's a honor in a great pleasure to
be invited today to celebrate Pat and
the success of the McGovern Institute I
was looking through my slides and I
didn't have a picture of Pat that
reflected how I knew him and that is as
an extraordinarily happy engaged leader
somebody who was as Laurie has just said
optimistic action oriented in a
visionary in terms of the future of
neuroscience so I found this slide just
to give you some indication how early
Pat had these traits that graduated from
MIT in 1959 he was a double major
between biology and computer science and
he came to MIT because he wanted to be
able to design computers that could
think and learn like the human and he
thought he needed to learn some
neuroscience so he came to MIT and
graduated in biology did research here
in neuroscience and Pat made the
decision visionaries have to be able to
make these decisions that his he was
ahead of this time in just the field and
the science was not ready in 59 to
integrate how we learn with computers
computers had not caught up he graduated
from MIT started as a writer for a
computer and automation of one of the
first publications in the field of
computer science five years later he
started IDG IDC actually and issued the
first
publication in in the computer world and
in three years later 27 he established
his first company and at 30 he launched
computer world and as they say the rest
is history he at
IDG as it was a mature company had 280
independent publications in 80 different
countries so he was an extraordinary
this visionary he was an extraordinary
business person and today in the New
York Boston Globe on the editorial page
there is a article by Glenn Rifkin on
his new book about that the governor as
a leader in business now Pat had all
this success but throughout his life and
when I met him
in 1998 he remained that he retained
this fascination with the human brain
and neuroscience and he was very excited
about returning to that subject and
being involved in neuroscience here at
MIT so I first met Pat and Laurie in
1998 at that time I was chair of the
Department of Biology I had been chair
for about seven years and as anyone
knows leading an organization by the
time you have seven years into an
organization you're covering up your
previous mistakes by making new mistakes
it was time to find another job but the
real motivation that got me interested
in being involved with the McGovern
Institute was that when I took the
chairmanship a biology I wanted to
expand neuroscience MIT I was confident
was under invest
in neuroscience it was a science that
was going to transform our future it was
going to transform how we understood the
human as a biological organism and
mankind as people that interacted if you
think about it it's pretty obvious that
our most unique attribute is our brain
is our ability to think our ability to
learn our ability to act and
understanding the biological basis of
that process and how it evolved and how
we can use it better will be an enormous
transformation in society it'll help us
learn more efficiently communicate more
efficiently it'll be the basis of
economic development as it is now
apparent it'll be the basis of being
able to solve some of the most difficult
medical and mental problems of society
it's transformational and when pat was
introduced to me by Chuck vest and Lori
I was very excited about the fact that
MIT might be able to expand neuroscience
with their excitement and their
resources the other reason it was the
time as a computational power had become
sufficiently powerful that one could
think of the integration of that
technology was molecular and genetic
technology transforming the rate at
which progress was going to be made in
neuroscience so I was invited down to
the IDG headquarters where I met Lori
and Pat on Beacon Street and it was a
exciting moment for me and I think it
was a very exciting moment for them now
the McGovern Institute was building on a
strong palette form at MIT it was too
small but it was strong it was a program
in brain and cognitive
ants that haunts tuber launched in 1964
and then in 1993 the department of brain
and cognitive science was established
here at MIT with Emilio beatsie as its
leader in the center for learning and
memory had been established under the
leadership of Susumu tonegawa so we had
this movement of MIT in establishing
neuroscience here and expanding
neuroscience in the late 90s mid 90s
but with Pat and Laurie's commitment of
350 million dollars forced over 20 years
to establish the McGovern Institute it
became very clear that there was a new
opportunity at MIT to change
neuroscience at this institution so this
is a few slides from 2002 which was our
first board meeting and I found these as
I was thinking about this lecture uh and
this is my first statement about the
McGovern Institute the purpose of the
McGovern Institute is to investigate and
ultimately understand the biological
basis of higher functions of the human
brain now I know this statement was
crafted as a molecular and cell
biologist which is what I am and I made
it clear to the community that I was
excited about leading this but I was not
going to become a neuroscientist because
I didn't think I could do it in the time
that was necessary to actually be a
neuroscientist and make a difference
in that field but I still think that
this is a very powerful objective
biological basis and function of the
human brain but it also is one in which
many other attributes play a role in
leading us to understand in time with
these objectives how the brain works the
excitement of that meeting was the
statement about the launch of the
Institute one of the important decisions
that we made at the beginning working
with Pat and Laurie who had previously
had experience with the Whitehead
Institute is that this Institute would
be modeled on the shape and size of the
Whitehead Institute and that was very
important not only because there's real
momentum when you have 16 or so
investigators committed to a common
cause but in a more practical sense it
meant there had to be 85,000 square foot
of space built somewhere doctor to house
this building and 85,000 square foot of
space was more than MIT could stick in a
corner somewhere so that led us to the
idea of moving to this corner of Main
Street in Albany and establishing a
whole new building of three Institute's
the brain and cognitive Department the
McGovern and the pick are ultimately the
pick are here on the corner of Main
Street and Albany and that transformed
MIT in neuroscience forever and it has
led to leadership in this community by
this institution now Charles Correa was
selected as the architect of the
Institute a very distinguished and in
nationally-known architect and he soon
and goodie and Clancy was was retained
to design the interior structure of the
building because they had built many
labs around MIT and therefore the the
Magnificent building that you're sitting
in today came into fruition and this is
a picture of a schematic that was
I don't know graphic that was produced
which turned out to be this marvelous
building of neuroscience here at MIT
Charles Correa after he designed the
building and after the building was
built kept telling me remember this is a
ship moving through Cambridge to the
east this building was designed on that
basis so look at that you see the bow of
the ship you see the smokestacks at the
top and it's plowing to the east with
the curved surface and he was very
concerned so I want to get this in the
MIT memory he was very concerned that
over to the your left that the Parsons
building not disappear because he said
this building can't be understood unless
the Parsons building is there because
it's plowing through the Parsons
building to the east and he doesn't want
it replaced with a park what's a
building there this is so that's the
design of the building but as you know
the building had one other trait and
that is the train tracks and we had to
deal with the train tracks because there
was all sorts of concern that the
vibrations of the train coming through
the building through the building you're
sitting on top of a train track here
coming through the building would
disrupt all the very high precision
instruments that you have to have to do
recording in the nervous system in
preparations well it turned out that the
engineers and the physicists and others
at MIT could solve that problem but the
problem wasn't a train tracks the
problem was the subway system over there
because the train only runs two times a
day that subway system runs every 5 10
20 minutes and that is lots of magnetic
and vibrations waves that could come
into the building so as you know this
building is set on piers driven down 200
or so feet in bedrock and it sort of
sets and vibrates slowly because of the
mass on top of that and then it became
this beautiful atrium which I think is
the most attractive interior space on
the MIT campus it brings us together
it's a beautiful home for a community to
really have an enormous impact in
advancing neuroscience and making a
difference in the world so we designed
the building and it came into fruition
the research vision that really was the
basis of the early days of the McGovern
Institute is here systems and
computational neuroscience imaging and
cognitive neuroscience and genetic and
cellular neuroscience and that was
manifest in the faculty who in 2003 were
part of the McGovern Tommy Poggio was
the associate director of the McGovern
and I had the great pleasure of working
with Tommy and bringing the McGovern
Institute into its
existence Amelio beatsie and gray bill
and Nancy kanwisher
were all part of the original four
people in neuroscience who actually knew
neuroscience as we put it together we
recruited in the first year or so
Jim DeCarlo Chris Moore and Michael fee
and as you know Jim and Michael are
central leaders in in the McGovern
Institute and have made major
contributions to science and then in
genetic and cellular neuroscience Bob
Horowitz and Martha Constantine Patten
joined us and led us in molecular and
genetic neuroscience so that was the
early days of the establishment of the
govern Institute and here's a picture of
the breaking ground for the building and
that is the the community that watched
this building come you can see Laurie
and Pat there Pat is very happy in what
is the coming Institute at MIT we
watched the building go up and at the
same time and I want to use this to
comment in 2003 we held a symposium the
first major symposium of the McGovern
Institute and this was two years before
we occupied the building and we had a
star-studded speaker series for that
symposium some from internal some many
from out external around the world and
what was really striking from the
beginning of the McGovern Institute
- when it was established in - times is
just how strong support for the
Institute has been by the national and
international neuroscience community it
is been lifted by our colleagues who's
helped us recruit communicate the
importance of this field and benefit
from the activity in this field so
neuroscience as a as a field has grown
at MIT with a national and international
support and as you know the McGovern
Institute as a family now is clearly an
international organization now
everything is very successful and I'll
come back to it in a moment
but one thing didn't get built they're
still talking about it
I look at they're talking about it down
a elevated passage over Vassar Street
detecting the McGovern and the
neuroscience complex to the rest of MIT
in a Central Corridor and this became a
budgetary issue and we still await being
connected to the rest of the Institute
but I look back on this
say 20 years or 19 years in specific
from 2002 from the first announcement of
the McGovern Institute to where them a
govern Institute is now in the
contributions it's made and we're
neuroscience is and it's been an
extraordinary journey and I complement
Bob DeSimone and the leadership of the
McGovern Institute it's faculty the
supporting community and brain and
cognitive science and in the pic our for
making MIT such a special place for
neuroscience
you are going to change the world in
biological and life science there's no
question about it
MIT is going to be changed by you and
that's terribly exciting and to have a
little part of the beginning of that
just a little part but being able to say
let's do it I'll help you it's been
extraordinarily gratifying the last
thing I will say to you as I was saying
to Bob this morning that the biomedical
side of neuroscience is about to explode
and the reason for that is that I think
we're going to have success in changing
the course of Alzheimer's I think we'll
have success then in changing the course
of many other diseases that are metal
genetics is advancing rapidly new
therapeutic modalities such as oolagah
nucleotides is dancing rapidly imaging
is advancing rapidly so I think there
will be an increasing emphasis or or
activity in that domain
I'm sure this complex McGovern and the
brain and cog will be part of that it'll
also be a larger community but it is
something that I feel
is really going to change over the next
10 years so I congratulate you I think
you Laurie
and Pat for making this happen it's been
extraordinary thank you
[Applause]